hello people of america today here
from the grounds of the capital back
there in my background
helping today feed national
guard and security forces the u.s
capitol police
and many other people that came to make
sure that
everybody is safe
that's celebrity chef and humanitarian
activist jose andreas at the u.s capitol
after the january 6th insurrection he's
doing what he does
best responding to a crisis with a slice
of comfort
his organization world central kitchen
distributed free meals
to thousands of national guard members
and capitol police last month
but with a new administration in place
the famed restauranteur is not just
focused
on charity he's cooking up a recipe to
change laws
one of them the fema empowering
essential deliveries act also known
as feed the chef has teamed up with
several lawmakers to introduce that bill
aiming to give
a desperately needed boost to
restaurants during the pandemic
it also works to feed countless
americans who are unable to put food on
the table
joining us now is the man best known for
helping to heal the world through food
award-winning chef jose andreas thank
you so much for coming back
on the show uh although we know the
pandemic has hit the restaurant industry
particularly hard
they're struggling to stay in business
families are struggling as a direct
result of that too
tell us about the feed act and the other
legislation you're backing what they do
well obviously we we began talking about
the health crisis we were having the
economic crisis but i
felt we forgot at the beginning of this
pandemic
to talk about the humanitarian food
crisis we were going through
and these for us at world central
kitchen for me was very simple
if we had the restaurant industry
shut down who better than
restaurants and chefs and food people
to feed america what wall central
kitchen did almost 40 million meals
serve
so far on this pandemic alone we did
that we began partnering
with almost 3 000 restaurants across
america making sure that we could
distribute the money that people were
supporting us with
paying those restaurants per meal making
sure that in
every city in every community elderly
homes
hospitals first responders homeless
could be getting a plate of food in
moments
of need that's what the feed act is and
there is when you see
where good policy is good politics
hunger and food should not be an issue
of the right
or the left is about americans taking
care of americans in a moment of me
very much so and just moving beyond the
pandemic talking about hunger and food
and nutrition let's throw that in there
you've talked about the need for the
biden administration to create a role
for a national director of food and
nutrition
talk about that role and why it's needed
now more than ever before
i do believe that while the usda is a
very important tool to make sure that
agriculture is run well and food
programs are run well i think
secretary bilsek is the right person for
the moment
the previous experience he have is gonna
be very important
in this very complicated moment but i do
believe that food is bigger than the
usda
itself what is also immigration
immigration reform homeland security
has to be there also the department of
housing and urban development
needs to be there next to usda to make
sure that we will never again have
any more food deserts in many parts
of america at the end of the day food
very much
is a national security issue we can be
taking care of many problems if we are
able to bring the entire force of the
federal government
making sure the way that we have now um
um
secretary perry uh who is going to be
leading
all the climate change and environment
uh uh changes that the biden
administration is going to be endorsing
i do believe
that we need to start having people next
to the white house next to the president
making sure
that we bring the full force of the
federal government like for example
fema i believe they've been missing in
action during this pandemic
cannot be that the agency in charge of
emergencies
is absent in a moment that so many
americans during the last year
were going hungry we need to make sure
that the entire
government solves this issue
one of the things we've been covering on
this show is the 15
minimum wage as part of joe biden's
proposed 1.9 trillion dollar
relief package uh it'll clearly help
fight poverty that's
you know beyond dispute but a lot of
small businesses including restaurants
worry it'll hurt their bottom line
where do you stand on increasing the
minimum wage to 15
listen what understanding is that we
need to be talking even
bigger than what is the minimum wage we
need to be talking about what's the
living wage
i do believe every single american
doesn't matter what political party you
are
they will say that people don't want our
pity people
want our respect how do we give them
respect by making sure that
every american has a living wage we
don't want to see
americans in hunger lines in food banks
waiting for hours for a box of food
we need to make sure that we take care
of those americans when they go through
hard times
and one way to do this is obviously good
unemployment but obviously the
essential workers that through this
pandemic
while many americans they've been in the
comfort and safety of their homes
many of those food workers which is
bigger than restaurant workers
is everybody that is part of feeding
america
from farmers to the guys doing
distribution obviously
all the way to the restaurant workers we
need to make sure that
those those workers are taken care of
let's make sure that we have a big uh uh
conversation about what's the right
living wage so
every single american can take care of
their families
on their own so
on that note earlier what do you make of
republican senators mitt romney and tom
cotton saying today
they'll support gradual increases in the
minimum wage
only if it's tied to a crackdown on
businesses employing
undocumented immigrants sounds like a
dog whistle to me
listen i think that sometimes in
politics everybody tries to bring
different issues to
try uh to say why they are against one
thing or the other but let me tell you
right now in america in this pandemic
the more than 11 million
undocumented workers they've been the
ones
putting food in every supermarket so
those senators those congressmen and
every american could feed their families
i do believe that immigration reform
it's not a problem for america to solve
but an opportunity for america to cease
let's make sure once and for all we pass
immigration reform
and at the same time this cannot be done
at the expense of taking care of every
single
american that somehow even by working
they cannot make it at the end of the
month to put
food on the table i think we need to
address both issues
and with those both shoes resolved
america will do so much better
i completely agree with you uh jose you
announced on twitter that you'll be
appearing on michelle obama's upcoming
uh children's cooking show on netflix uh
we know as first lady she launched the
let's move campaign to help and
uh childhood obesity how did that
collaboration come about it seems like a
pretty good fit for you listen
uh at the very beginning of the obama
administration
uh first lady obama with
the food advisor they had sam cass and
president obama
they invited over a thousand chefs to
the grounds of the white house
the message was very clear in order to
make sure that america will be fed
better from schools to the quality and
the nutrition that we feed our children
that we need to be bringing food
professionals and everybody else to the
table
to solve this problem probably one of
the biggest legacies
that michelle obama is going to have is
this show this show is going to be
watching american around the world
and for me that the first lady is going
to be doing a show that continues
her efforts in the white house with the
garden the let's move campaign
through a show that is going to be
enjoyed by everybody and where the
message is going to be
clear let's celebrate food let's
celebrate good food
and let's bring everybody into the
question this show may become one of the
biggest legacies of michelle obama just
wait and see
i was very proud that they invite me and
i i cannot say much more i'm gonna let
them keep doing the
announcements but i'm very proud that i
am one of the people
uh partnering on that show and being
part of look forward to
i look forward to seeing you on there um
last question before we run out of time
you're partnering with prince harry and
meghan markle as well to build
community relief centers in regions hit
by natural disasters the structures are
meant to function as schools as medical
clinics community centres
they can essentially become whatever is
needed tell us about that project why it
made sense to partner
with these two people listen uh there is
no
no doubt that uh uh prince harry and
megan they are people of action
obviously they they they bring uh a a
a wealth of of possibilities having them
and joining us supporting what we
are doing is great to have people like
them supporting organization
that we were very small 10 years ago but
that
over the last years you know take a look
on this pandemic alone
we've been feeding people not only
through the pandemic hospitals and
beyond but we've been in fires
in hurricanes in the explosion in beirut
in lebanon
in back-to-back hurricane uh category
five in honduras colombia
we've been in so many countries in this
pandemic around the world for me
it's an honor to have those two
individuals uh
uh supporting us and working together uh
prince harry has told me jose next
opportunity
i want to be there on the ground with
you they've shown before that they've
been there
next to the people even when the cameras
were not around i love that they are
supporting us
and supporting many other organizations
we're
we're out of time but thank you so much
for coming on the show
chef jose andres keep doing what you do
appreciate it
hi i'm mehdi hussain thanks for checking
out our channel on youtube you can see
more of the mehdi hassan show
by clicking on any of the videos on this
screen and make sure you subscribe
below to stay up to date on the day's
biggest stories thank you for watching